you started with the beautiful magic
carpet ride and so you know we're gonna
be obsessed with your love life until
the end of time and so who would you
like to see on your magic carpet in the
future me and my my dog Rosco there any
chance that now that they've broken up
it could be a tie again
ha hi-c I don't know what you're talking
about
like a nice Tyler see Tyler
I'm riding my carpet right now so yeah
Alan would you join I think the carpet
broke down were from now on I loved in
the package you were talking about how
fitting this was a whole new world and
like your world has been ripped wide
open what has been the thing that has
been the greatest and what has been the
thing that you're like you know what I
wouldn't I would take that back if I
could I mean they they kind of go hand
in hand
I think sometimes it's hard when you put
your whole personal life out for
everyone to see
and to judge and that can be difficult
because privacy becomes hard but at the
same time with that the encouragement
and the support and the ability to
connect with people I never would have
been able to is so rewarding and so I
think it makes it so much better and Val
you need to go away I'm trying to finish
these important questions with our
people want to know
Bruno Tonioli
[Music]
listen the first nines we've seen this
entire season and you got a couple of
them you got to be so proud I'm so
excited about the nines I love this
dance and Disney and I I've been looking
forward to it so it was a really fun
time and proud of the nine Len Len with
your seven grumpy old land even on
business that huh it's all right you
know what we're gonna take all the
criticism as a stepping stone and to
grow from it and it was amazing and
we're really excited to move forward no
one went home wanted more hold so I'll
remember that
[Music]
[Applause]